that's what she told me
all right well thank you
yeah we're fine here we go
yeah well yeah oh what are you saying
that you were
from the other network
okay
who was that was that nick
oh
yeah it confuses me because
i'm just a
you know i do anticipate well so
you're thank you
it must be good
they were doing that
i am
i was
you
you couldn't stand up there could you
stand up at the podium for me
i need to focus
please
thank you
true
um
uh
a minute
okay
white
is
ladies
questions
thank you
ready
i i don't know how hard
hello
uh
so
okay
thank you
yeah up at 6am
uh
that's a problem
can you show me
thank
yeah
hey
foreign
uh
you're doing good
um
um
i know
uh
please
i'm on tv
good
oh
okay
i don't know i think it was like
six or seven pounds
oh
oh yeah
is
this happens
the president
let's take care of themselves
again
honestly
uh
so those cameras
is
is
bro
oh
might be the white house
um
okay
oh
he said
right
a minute
yes
six
yeah stuff it can't
i mean it can be
i usually have one or two days of
cleanup day
so i have a process of
um
it's too
like i had one
like if um gets really dry then i just
put it in bag and let it completely dry
and then when i figure out the trash i
take it out of the bag so i'm going
straight into there
so you know it'll break down even in the
trash
i just wish i had a killer
um
what's up guys
um
i got his lens in my picture
he pulls his back
um
uh
coming here folks
got it good
is
um
um
i feel like i'm here
foreign
here
thank you very much thank you everybody
thank you we've had a tremendous week
uniting the
entrepreneur fight against the china
virus i've
reminded people of the importance of
masks
when you can't socially distance in
particular a strong message has been
sent out to young people to stop too
crowded bars and other crowded places
yesterday we made the amazing
announcement
for our plans to protect nursing home
residents we're working very hard on
that we're doing very well
all over the country and also about
contracting with uh pfizer we made a big
big beautiful contract with pfizer we
think they're very close but we have
a lot of companies that are very close
to produce a
and i wanted to come out again today to
share some
additional news with you this afternoon
my political team came to me and laid
out
our plans for the convention in
jacksonville florida
it's a place i love i love that state
the drawings look absolutely beautiful i
never thought we could have something
look
so good so fast with everything going on
and everything was going well a
tremendous list of speakers
thousands of people wanting to
be there and i mean in some cases
desperately be there
they wanted to attend people making
travel arrangements all over the country
they wanted to be there
the pageantry the signs the excitement
were really really
top of the line but i looked at my team
and i said
the timing for this event is not right
it's just not right with what's happened
recently the flare-up in florida
to have a big convention it's not the
right time
it's uh really something that
for me i have to protect the american
people
that's what i've always done that's what
i always will do that's what i'm about
they said sir we can make this work very
easily
we have great enthusiasm incredible
enthusiasm
even the polls say about the most
enthusiasm they've seen
we can do this safely and we can do it
responsibly i said there's
nothing more important in our country
than keeping our people safe
whether that's from the china virus or
the radical left mob
that you see in portland where i want to
thank
homeland security and others in law
enforcement for doing a fantastic job
over the last few days they went in
and people were out of control for 51
days
a long time and homeland security and
other law enforcement with us went in
and they've done a great job
protecting our property federal
courthouse and
other property and most importantly
protecting our people or the senseless
violence that you see in chicago or new
york or
detroit a lot of other cities where so
many people are shot
and so many people are killed and
people uh elected me to help and to
protect
so i told my team it's time to cancel
the jacksonville
florida component of the gop
convention we'll be starting in north
carolina for the monday as
has always been planned we were never
taking that off that's remaining as it
is the delegates are going to get
together that's
where they do their nomination so the
delegates are
going to north carolina and they'll be
doing
the nomination and we're going to do
some other things with
teller rallies and online the week that
we're discussing which will be
really good i think we're going to do it
well and i'll
still do a convention speech in a
different form
but we won't do a big crowded convention
per se it's just not the right time for
that
i care deeply about the people of
florida and everywhere else frankly in
this country and even in the world
who would be coming into the state and i
don't want to do anything to upset it
they'll be doing very well very shortly
we're going to put some
maps up of the country behind me and
you'll see that
the area that we're talking about is a
hot spot
you'll also see a lot of the country is
uh has
has no problem whatsoever most of the
country actually
so i'm always going to take care of you
so that
that's the way we're going to do it i've
spoken to
governor desantis and informed other
political leaders i want to
thank the jacksonville
community and its great mayor he's great
great guy
really great guy they wanted it so badly
and
all of the other political
representatives in jacksonville and in
florida
and just very special people a very
special group
and they were there for us a hundred
percent
today i want to provide an update on the
actions we're taking to support the safe
reopening of america's schools
parents around the world who have had
their children home
for the last few months of a greater
appreciation for the fact
that teachers are essential workers that
they're essential to our
children's future must protect our
teachers and students from the china
virus
while ensuring that families with high
risk factors can continue to participate
from home very important the american
academy of
pediatrics has released guidance
recommending that
schools reopen it said quote
lengthy time away from school an
associated
interrupt of supportive services
often results in a social isolation
making it difficult for schools to
identify
and address important learning deficits
as well as
child and adolescent physical and sexual
abuse
substance abuse depression and suicidal
ideation this in turn places children an
adolescent
terrible risk of morbidity and of
some cases mortality beyond the
educational impact and social impact of
school closures
there's been a substantial impact on
food security and physical activity for
children and for families
so that's very important and there's a
highway it goes both ways the national
education association recently
stated despite the momentous efforts of
educators during the pandemic online
learning has never been
an effective replacement for in-person
learning
and support being at the school being on
the campus is very
very important one study estimates that
due to school closures last spring
the average student will be in the
school year roughly 35
behind in reading compared to the
typical year
and more than 50 percent behind in math
that's a big statement
according to mckinsey and company
learning loss will probably be
greatest among low-income black and
hispanic
students they're the ones that are hit
the hardest we don't want that happening
3 million american students rely on
schools for free and reduced meals
over 70 percent of the students who
receive mental health services do so
through their schools
according to hhs one in five reports
allegedly having to do with child abuse
they have neglect and these are neglect
and neglected cases are submitted by
education
personnel so people
in the education world on the premises
will be the ones that report neglect
and other problems when they see the
children they know if they've been
neglected they know if they've been hurt
or harmed in any way
whether it's at home or someplace else
but they see this at school you don't
get to see that if you're not going to
school it's a big
fortunately the data shows the children
are lower risk from the china virus very
substantially
when children do contact the virus they
often follow
very mild symptoms or none at all
and medical complications are
exceedingly rare
those that do face complications often
have underlying
medical conditions 99
of all china virus hospitalizations
are adults and 99.96 percent of all
fatalities are adults that means that
children are a tiny percentage less than
one percent and even a small percentage
of one percent
in a typical year the flu results in
more deaths
of those under 18 united states have
been
lost thus far to the coronavirus
many different names many many different
names
the life of every child is sacred and
must be affected
our sole focus is the health and
well-being of america's
children i have a very very special
person who loves children who's
who's the greatest athletes of all time
a lot of people say the greatest pitcher
of all time
known as a relief pitcher could have
been whatever he wanted some people
he is the greatest reliever of all time
by far substantially more safe
than what he lost in fact he got the
presidential
medal of freedom recently and uh
he uh i'm reading off these stats i knew
he was the best i knew he was great but
i didn't know it was almost double
anybody
else but he's a man who loves children
has children loves children
works hard with children we're going to
go outside and be with some little
leaguers
mariano rivera you know he's the same
man right my wife said
darling why do they call him the sandman
i said you know they play the song
he just puts the batters to sleep and
that's exactly what happened
so uh mariano here is a great honor
thank you very much was talking
about children in schools and
there's nobody that's done more than you
have thank you very much marianna
fantastic man considerations we believe
many
school districts can now reopen safely
provided they implement
mitigation measures and health protocols
to protect families
and to protect students and we do have
to protect
the teachers and the families also we
have to remember that all families
should be empowered to make the decision
that is right for their own
this is especially important if a child
has underlying health conditions or
lives with a parent or grandparent who's
at higher risk
in cities or states that are
current hospitals behind me
districts may need to delay reopening
for
a few weeks and that's possible that'll
be up to governors
the decision should be made based on the
data and
the fact that community but every
district should be actively making
preparations to open
again the children obviously have a very
strong
immune system maybe even the strongest
they seem to be able to fight it off and
not have a problem
so uh it's pretty amazing actually great
great credit
our strategy to safely
mirrors our approach nationwide
as we race toward the completion of a
vaccine and therapeutics
the responsible path is to shelter those
at higher
those that lower risk much lower in the
case of
young children to resume work at school
and
as long as everyone practices vigilant
hygiene
and social distancing we want that a
permanent shutdown was never the
strategy which would ultimately lead to
greater mortality and irreversible harms
we don't want to do that
at the same time we have to get our
economy going we had tremendous numbers
issued yesterday housing prices pricing
of housing
up 21 is the highest in history
it's the highest number in history real
estate housing
went up 21 today the cdc will provide
additional guidance for how schools can
reopen safely
i hope that local leaders put the full
health and well-being of their students
first and to make the right decision for
children parents teachers and not make
political decisions this isn't about
politics it's about something
very very important this is not about
politics
i even think it's bad politics if you do
the wrong decision very bad politics
we're asking congress to provide
105 billion dollars to schools as part
of the next coronavirus
relief bill this funding will support
mitigation measures such as smaller
class sizes more teachers and teacher
aids
repurposing spaces to practice social
distancing and crucially
mask wearing this money is an
we additional for schools and
universities earlier this year
that money we have some is distributed
and some is not distributed
if schools do not reopen the funding
should go
their child to public private charter
religious or
home school of their choice the key word
being
choice if the school is closed the money
should follow the student so the parents
and families
are in control of their own decisions so
we'd like the money to go to the
parents of the student this way they can
make the decision that's best
we cannot indefinitely stop 50 million
american children from going to school
harming their mental physical and
emotional
development reopening our schools is
also
the parents can go to work and provide
for their families
the council of economic advisors
estimates that 5.6 million parents will
be unable to return to work
if schools do not reopen this year
a tremendous problem it's a tremendous
problem
schools have to open safely they have to
open
more than a dozen european countries as
well as south korea
taiwan and many others have already
reopened schools and
cases have not risen we can achieve the
same goal if we unite together follow
the benefits
and apply common sense
we'll continue to support states and
cities in the
current hot spots in the south southwest
and west
governors i know them all they're all
very very capable they're doing a very
good job they're working
so hard you wouldn't even believe it we
have nearly 30
000 federal personnel deployed in the
states
that need assistance we're helping with
doctors and nurses
medical personnel of all kinds
as a ppe update we're in close
communication with
we have supplies everything they could
possibly need
we're very strong on supplies remember i
used to say the cupboards were bare well
now the cupboards are the opposite
due to our both the national stockpile
and the
state stockpiles the vast majority of
the states have 60 days worth of
supplies on hand
and most importantly they have
ventilated ventilators are
very very hard to come by at least in
the past now we're making thousands of
ventilators a month
and supplying them in many cases to
other countries
for states that are making requests for
mentally delivering
in the last 24 hours fema has deployed
more than
1.5 million masks upon request
1.7 million gallons and 600
uh well let me change that we've created
about 600
000 different supplies we have 600
ventilators
to arizona north carolina pennsylvania
colorado and washington i think the
number is
600 we're going to check that and we'll
give it to you
in a little while but we've we've got a
stockpile of
thousands of ventilators down about
600 just recently the united states has
now conducted more than
51 million tests which is more than
any other country in the world by far
half of the tests are either the rapid
point of care test which frankly
solves a lot of problem and delay five
to fifteen minutes instead of waiting
for services
and then at the lab but roughly half of
them now which is a tremendous
increase are five to 15 minute tests or
tests done in a hospital
less than a day some cases immediately
we're
continuing to surge testing to current
hot spots such as miami and phoenix to
detect those with the
steps to stop from spreading it
further this is a copy of the map
and this is uh you have it right behind
me that's uh
indicating where the problems you see
from
from that it's in great shape lots of it
the northeast has become
very clean the country is
then if you look south and west some
problems
that'll all work out on therapies we've
worked with florida to ensure that
over 40 thousand vials from deaths
severe are arriving this week
it's a lot that's a really that's a lot
they're working around the clock to
make it it's had a tremendous impact
we've also shipped thousands of vials to
california and texas over the past two
weeks
arizona is doing very well it's heading
down numbers are heading down
i think very quickly governor's done a
great job they've all
done a great job working hard we'll
continue to monitor the areas rising and
with respect to cases and we ask all
americans to exercise
vigilance practical distancing wear a
mask
do whatever is necessary so we get rid
of this horrible
situation this horrible disease that was
sent to us by china
it should not have been sent he they
could have stopped it they didn't
and the entire world has gotten infected
and a lot of countries are going
through a lot right now this morning i
spoke with
putin of russia and they're going
through a very hard time with this
in moscow in particular i spoke to
the crown prince saudi arabia uh
they're not everybody's going through a
lot yesterday i spoke to the heads of
four different countries
uh all four are going through a lot
going through a hard time
this could have been stopped it could
have been stopped quickly and easily but
for some reason
and we'll figure out what that reason
was so with that if you have any
questions
please
from the convention were you simply not
convinced that you could keep people
safe
as a conviction i just felt it was wrong
steve to have
people going to what turned out to be a
hot spot you know when we chose it it
was not at all hot it was
free and all of a sudden happen quickly
it happens quickly and it goes away and
it goes away quickly
uh the key is we wanted to go away
without a lot of
death without a lot of problems and
we're learning so much about
that's why we're we're very cognizant of
nursing homes we're watching them very
carefully and people over a certain age
and especially people over a certain age
with diabetes or
or heart disease in particular but with
a problem
so uh we didn't want to take any chances
so we had a lot of people we have
the delegates want to be there we're
going to do a
fairly reasonably quick meeting in north
carolina the nomination will be returned
and then we'll announce what we're doing
how we're doing it whether it's
uh something that's done online i guess
you could call it online
so uh there can nothing there could be
nothing like our last convention
unfortunately that was a great
convention and a great place as you know
we had a we had a great time great time
in cleveland
but um it's a different world and it
will be for a little while we want to
get the world back
to what it was and i think we'll have
that including
great job numbers uh including so many
things that happen
positive i have to say the stock market
is close to records for nasdaq
it is a record it's already exceeded its
highest numbers
uh but we want to get our country back
what it was
acceptance fees being from the white
house we haven't said that yet
see we'll have that we'll probably
announce that over the next few days
look we've done a great job we built the
greatest economy in the world
no nobody close not china not anybody
we had to close it we saved millions of
lives and we opened it but we had the
best numbers in history for
african americans hispanic americans
asian americans
every group you want to name young
people without a diploma young
people with a high school diploma with a
college student
anything you want to name we had the
best numbers women doing incredibly
never never been a time like that and we
had to
turn it off because of what china did
we had to turn it off and then all of a
sudden uh
now we turn it back on and we're doing
very well but it was a
very bad china speaking about china the
trade deal
means less to me now than it did when i
made it it was a great deal
but they're uh they're setting records
yesterday was a record corn day they
purchased more corn than any order ever
and that went on for two or three days
and
soybeans and all but it just means much
less to me can you understand that
just means much less to me please go
ahead thank you what was the one thing
if there was one thing that changed your
mind about the convention
did florida officials ask you to cancel
it
no they didn't we're dealing with them
but they didn't i would just say safety
just safety i just you know i could see
uh
the media saying this is i don't want to
be in that position
it's safety not because of the media but
that's what they would say
and uh we'll have a very nice something
we'll figure it out it'll be
uh it'll be online in some form maybe
it'll be
something even a little bit different we
have time you know we're talking about
the end of
august but uh i think it'll be something
that will be
exciting but there could be nothing like
having
25 000 people we had a tremendous thing
planned and
a tremendous convention planned in north
carolina
and it would have been very good but a
much smaller version
then we saw what was happening pretty
quickly we saw that
that the virus was coming up that coast
so
the severity of the situation in florida
no i think it's going to come and go it
will i mean you take a look at some of
these locations
were heavily infected i mean to a point
where
deborah and i were talking that you know
when you look at what happened in new
york what happened in new jersey and
other places
and now you're looking and uh it's gone
i hope it stays gone i think we i think
it will but we had to be
we had to be we have to be we have to be
careful
and we also have to set an example i
think setting the example is very
important
uh it's hard for us to say we're going
to have a lot of people packed in a room
and then
other people shouldn't do it don't
forget we're talking about schools
and we want them to be vigilant and
we're saying open
and then we're saying here you have a
big room but i also if you notice i said
where bars are crowded where other
things are credible nothing more crowded
than a convention a convention i mean
you've seen them
and even though you try and keep people
away from each other it's just not that
kind of a thing they probably
can't do that it just doesn't work for
them so it's a very
so i think we're setting an example by
doing it is very important
yeah john mr president if i could come
back to uh school
openings you talked about money that
congress is looking at to help schools
uh who want to reopen if school wants to
reopen this concerned about
testing would you consider directing
some of that money toward testing for
either a school district or even
individual schools
if that's what it took to open the
schools yeah i think so
i mean a lot of people feel differently
about
testing we talk about it a lot when we
have
50 million tests plus and you know we've
we broke the 50 million test mark
second in the world is india which is
1.4 billion people
and they had 12 million tests and other
countries that are very big had two
million tests
and some countries essentially only test
if you're sick walk into a hospital or
walk into a doctor's office or
you're literally really sick they
essentially don't do tests unless you're
sick
and i understand that too so yeah if
they feel that that's what they want
it's uh that would be fine you would
tell congress you would encourage
congress to pay for testing
i would if they want again we've done 50
million tests
there's nobody even close to the whole
world you look at our mortality rate you
look at our death rate you look at
different statistics we're doing very
well
but one death is too many this should
never have happened this should never
have been allowed to happen
from china also mitch mcconnell's office
uh just put out a statement a moment ago
about
the phase four relief package carriage
ii saying quote it's tailored precisely
for this phase of the crisis
it does not include your payroll tax cut
so do you believe it's from yeah i'd
like to see a payroll tax cut i think
it's great for the workers the democrats
would never have gone for it they don't
want it they're not big into the workers
i guess
and based on that i told them last night
i told the republicans who have been
working very hard on this i'll tell you
and they want what's right for the
country
and hopefully the democrats ultimately
will but i said i think apparel has to
be good
you're not going to get it from the
democrats we need their votes as you
know
it's not like you know we have a
majority but it's not enough that we
that's why i guess we have an election
coming up so you still need democrat
votes and we're not going to get the
democrat votes on that
so i'd like to see that it would be very
good for the workers but
if we're not going to get their votes i
guess we have to go on to the next thing
a payroll tax cut would have been very
good and maybe uh
maybe something happens uh yes please
um you talk about setting an example on
jacksonville but i i just wonder some
people are going to take away from this
the lesson
that you're pushing too far too fast it
seemed for a while the numbers were
going up in jacksonville we were going
to have a problem now
this comes up at a time looking for
schools to reopen have the opening of
the
major league baseball season isn't is
the example of jacksonville that we've
been pushing too fast
well baseball as an example we were
discussing a little while ago you're
going to be at a
empty stadium i've agreed randy levine's
a great friend of mine from the yankees
he asked me to throw out the first pitch
and i think i'm doing that on august
15th at yankee stadium
and i say how's the crowd gonna be and
uh you know
it's like you don't have a crowd there
is no such thing it's gonna be
interesting mariano he's not used to
that
i've been at many games it goes crazy
uh i think it'd be just as good without
the crowd you were just born with it you
know some people are born with it
uh i don't know if this is only for the
baseball players but i've never seen a
picture throwable where so many bats
were broken as mariano
he's got the all-time record i said how
do you do that he said parents
great parents when you get right down to
it right how do you do that it's called
parents
but but i just just to finish i think i
think that
we have to all set examples i think
major league baseball is setting an
example by
you know playing to empty stadiums and
so are other sports you see that
then they'll allow a certain number in i
see golf as now
soon will be allowing people to come in
and percentages and all of a sudden
we want to get back to normal the key is
to get back to normal because
nobody wants to see this but i think
it's really good that baseball is
opening it looks like football is
opening
it looks like sports are opening we we
have it's a tremendous thing
psychologically for our country
and uh we're all we're all with it we'll
see
we're going to see right now some
beautiful young
little leaguers outside with a great
future ahead of them
they're already practicing on the first
lawn of the white house
and we're going to go out and say hello
to them and it'll be really great okay
how about one more
yeah please go ahead president trump um
the washington post earlier today
reported that holding up the gop uh
coronavirus bill
is the white house asking that it
include language regarding the fbi
building in downtown washington dc is
that true
i don't know that they're putting it in
this bill but i know they want to have a
new fbi building this one is very
old and uh it's really was never built
to a very high standard as you probably
have heard and it's got a lot of danger
involved and
panels falling off the outside and
pieces of concrete falling off the
building
and they want to build it at the site
that they have it
they had options very far away from
washington
and i said to them frankly you have to
be near the justice department there's
nothing better than this
that they have now is better but they
were looking in sights in maryland and
virginia in different places
but they would have been too far away so
i am i've been encouraging them to build
it and if you're going to you have a
choice you can renovate the existing
building but it's not a good building
or you could take it down and build a
great building for the fbi for
100 years and have it be incredible even
with tracks on top they're talking about
you know we have
fbi people like to work out a lot and
you could have literally
a quarter mile tracks on top it's a very
big site very wide side
so i think the idea the best idea would
be to build a new building and that way
you have it for a long time renovation
can never be as good as a new building
in that case
i know they're talking about it whether
or not they put it in this bill or
someplace else but
the fbi needs a new building and we'll
get it done thank you all very much
thank you thank you very much
you